as freezing temperatures continue places
like this are offering respite from the
biting winter weather this library in
South London set up a warm bank for
local residents like Carol the 62 year
old says it's a Lifeline I'm afraid to
go out because it's too cold
it's too cold it's too cold in my house
and it's too cold outside so at least
come in here
it's not so bad Carol can't afford to
keep her home warm she spends as much
time as she can here when I'm here it's
like everything disappears I don't have
to worry about anything I haven't gone
until five of them here it's lovely and
then when I go home I know it's bedtime
because I don't have to take my my
medication tonight and then I go to bed
because what else is there it's going to
be freezing though and I don't want to
sit down in the front room that's cold
what's the TV I just lie in bed the cold
weather paired with Rising living costs
have intensified her arthritis the toll
on Carol's well-being has been huge
the joints are seized up and what's my
joints are seized I could barely walk
and it's it's depressing it does affect
your mental well-being a lot
a lot because I find myself very
isolated
um not wanting to speak to people
not caring
just feeling very low I never thought
that
if you retire this is what it's like I
never thought life got this bad how are
you feeling about the next couple of
months
well I'm not not looking forward to it
to be honest I try not to think about it
because uh if I think about it I'll feel
worse I don't know how I'm going to get
through well the Christmas spirit and
the new year after today's closing and
then opening in the new year and in the
new year
I don't know where I'm gonna be uh I
don't know as we enter a season filled
with festivities for Carol it's a season
filled with Dread all she wants is to
stay warm I shazid Sky News